[Music]
hello I'm in the stylish good guy
remember so you don't have to do you
hear the one about the guy who may one
of the worst films of all time yet
somehow won Best Picture got to be
funnier than anything in this
[Music]
movie 43 is a film I've been asked to
review for a while and is gaining a
reputation as one of the most puzzling
bad comedies ever made not for how
unfunny it is though yes it does succeed
spectacularly at that but rather because
how many big names were attached to it
names like Hugh Jackman Kate Winslet
Halle Berry Richard Gere Emma Stone
Kristen Bell Gerard Butler die Oh me
watts and that's just to name a few
directed by some other big names like
Peter Farley Elizabeth Banks James Gunn
Brett Ratner again just to name a few
with a tiny budget of only six million
dollars yeah that sounds like a lot but
to give you an idea who a Madea
Halloween cost 20 million to make the
surprisingly bigger question then why
the hell this movie was made is how the
hell this movie was made well almost
like in Apocalypse Now from a parallel
universe the making of this movie is
arguably more interesting than the movie
itself originally comedy producer
Charlie Wesler wanted to make the next
Kentucky Fried movie a collection of
fine shorts that push the envelope in
terms of good taste he described it as
funny or Die only you could go crazy
because Don Cheadle's Captain Planet was
too normal for it his plan was to have
three pairs of comedy directors take
one-third of the movie the Farley
Brothers the Zucker Brothers and Trey
Parker and Matt Stone interesting idea
but over time all the directors backed
out apart from one of the Farley's who
not only decided to joint development as
a producer as well but also happened to
be a very charming guy with a lot of
famous friends they first got Hugh
Jackman to agree who loved the idea of
doing something different and risque and
after much convincing of her agents that
got Kate Winslet as well this became the
movies pitching point we're doing a film
with a ton of big names it only takes a
few days to shoot and major stars Hugh
Jackman and Kate Winslet already filmed
well the pay was certainly low for a lot
of these big names but it was only for a
few days there's already big talent
involved and best of all they offer to
work around their schedules which meant
the film took over four years to make
with some celebrities even trying to get
out of it Richard Gere said he has to be
nice but said that he wouldn't be
available for over a year production had
to move from LA to New York and
they could only have him for four days
not a minute more
give Whistler and Farley credit they
worked within all the limitations both
the actors and directors laid out for
them
making this a very bizarre passion
project but still a passion project
nonetheless however with the strange mix
of both a large amount of time and a
short amount of time was there any
chance this movie would actually turn
out something of value and when I say
value I mean something anybody will put
on the resume in the future well let's
see the fruits of their labor of
lackluster love this is movie 43 it
opens with one kids like a dartboard add
another kid holding a dart in his mouth
Oh Amit I laughed at this but knowing
that Johnny Knoxville's in this movie I
somehow feel cheated it looks like this
is actually a video they uploaded online
and his little brother tricks them into
thinking it went viral yeah the only
thing going viral in this movie is
George Clooney's response when they
asked him to be in it look it up he said
that I took the liberty of cloning
YouTube and hyper-inflated your views
the boys look to get revenge by giving
the little brothers computer viruses so
they asked him to help looking for a
movie there's this movie on the internet
we can't find it I mean this video is so
illegal it has been banned like it's so
banned even Facebook Twitter and YouTube
think it's going too far if you can
watch it all the way through you're
rewarded beyond your wildest dreams no
that's kind of how this film works
except the reward for watching is abject
emptiness though it does last you all
your life if you haven't caught on this
is the sketch that loosely links all the
others together you're Rod Serling at
the script for an American Pie
straight-to-dvd movie anally assaulted
the charm out of him have fun with that
mental image the first video they find
is a sketch starring Kate Winslet and
Hugh Jackman the routine that launched a
thousand well they're in it but he's
probably got one of those awkward
character faces mister character face is
on the cover of Gotham magazine not him
well now these Dumpling Wolverine he's
gonna play Batman now I'm sorry my Bruce
Wayne Sparkle speaking of things that
should be banned I don't know how much
of this I can show but oh how do I put
it you Jackman has balls on his neck
that still doesn't sound right but
there's no way to say it so it does
sound right no omit the reveal at first
is sell out of nowhere in so matter of
I did get a legit laugh out of me but
take a guess how many other jokes they
have in this entire sketch you're right
this one this is the one joke they're
gonna have the whole time Craig did the
guy who produced the if Pat movie
producer oh come on
hook a pube falls and he eats it you're
on a life-size recreation of the Titanic
with Leonardo DiCaprio now you're
watching the greatest showman eat his
neck ball hair life is funny this movie
is deaf but life is funny look a baby
this has promised well if you Jackman's
ever a registered sex offender we now
know which picture to use wondering what
this is all building up to the balls
touch your face and that stops ya it
doesn't even really end it just stops I
think because Winslet said if they don't
fire three of my agents before they
shall cut I will do to their balls the
exact same thing they're currently doing
with Jackman's nobody could blame
pornographers one of the boys tries
putting viruses on the brothers computer
from a porn site as they look up the
next sketch and yes I too think there
should be a written law that lived
Schreiber and Hugh Jackman should never
be in a movie together again nothing
personally against him it's just bad
things happen
he and Naomi Watts play the parents of a
homeschooled shell they like to brag
about despite them being less than
Pleasant with them high school is about
more than just classes and homework
there's the alienation the loneliness
again the ideas okay as they say they
don't want him to miss out on what other
kids go through in school so they Boy
him and make him feel awkward and do all
sorts of terrible things but again you
know this is it this is the one joke
throughout the whole thing so you get a
second of laughter but a dozen minutes
of boredom
there's no spin uniqueness or adding on
top of the joke it's just the same stale
formula you're expecting it to end with
Stephen Segal telling you uncomfortable
audience how great they've been before
they cry drive their way home look they
even want to act out his first kiss he
doesn't want that okay give that kid an
Oscar because acting like you're not
interested in Niomi Watts his heart of
course I mean it that when they meet
them he seems well-adjusted enough but
enter punchline Jam my mom says hi yeah
I just saw make out with his mom how is
this supposed to be the surprising shock
ending the next sketch has Chris Pratt
getting ready to propose to Anna Faris
well this isn't uncomfortable there's
something I wanna ask you something I'd
like to ask you how about we say it at
the same time one two will you poop on
me that's surprisingly made things less
awkward this is the joke right it's all
gonna be poof related look she has
dumped on her apron look the frosting is
just like poo look they're talking about
poo look he gets him viagra for poo oh I
sure hope this ends with the golden
shower
a yellow sundress come on let me shit on
you please excuse as the word shit
instead of poo insulting her causing her
to run away where was she even gonna go
and a car hits and resulting in poo I'm
just gonna pretend this was funny hahaha
I couldn't even get free laughs out I'm
not that good an actor meanwhile the
younger brother obsesses with finding
the entire movie 43 I don't even get it
do they think they're watching it in
parts do they think they haven't found
it and they're just watching random
videos I know it's a nitpick but there's
so little funny it's the only thing I
can focus on the next sketch opens in a
grocery store with Keary and Culkin and
Emma Stone finally together at last
how's your acid reflux how's your HPV I
can't believe you sucked off that hobo
for magic bean he was wizard Neil Shh
I'll give him credit well it isn't
written very funny there die hard
commitment to these performances does
make it kind of giggle worthy I want to
be
all over your chin shit that made me
laugh dammit dammit do you still like
fingers in your butt oh you know the
answer is yes I'll see you in church
- it got to me
it is 100% their performances though
it's the sketch actually looks like it
might go to new territory with the
people in the store offering to take
over his shift so he can chase after her
my god
we might actually move on to something
else funny in this but then it just ends
Jesus Christ the one time you actually
had another joke and you stopped early
plus it just too much for you was having
a different joke follow another the
equivalent of going through the portal
in 2001 my gut piss yourself
such a lack of talent is not yet ready
for huh can make your woman that's it
now we're back to the trash I'm used to
the next sketch is Justin Long as Robin
and jason sudeikis as Batman ruining his
speed-date he's approached by uma
Thurman playing Lois Lane acting like
she wants to get this bit over with as
quickly as possible I thought you were
dating Superman has been stalking me
ever since really I look out my bedroom
window and there he is just floating
there and masturbating hey don't put
that past the DCE you they might work
that in Batman interrupts though by
calling Superman during their date I'm
sitting with Lois and she's got a date
with my boy okay it doesn't even matter
what the rest of this line is that edit
was funny well admit isn't funny as this
movie is there is still decent timing
with actors who don't know how to do
comedy they're just not given much to
work with if anything at all what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna get her at the
table hide down there and feed you lines
I'm gonna do it don't know anything that
brings the camera closer to his dick
Grace and I'm very against Kristen Bell
walks in as Supergirl as Batman tries to
feed him lines so where you from so were
you from Krypton Oh ask her about her
pool gloves
no seriously cool all that weird I can't
believe the size of this night's
enormous down here
I did not it's a huge bushy cash trophy
down here I'd like to think she was just
memorizing love as an open door in her
head during this hell maybe Hans turning
evil was her idea because it reminded
her of how she was betrayed by this
movie you can hear yeah I can hear him
hi
I skipped a day of ADR he's a good place
for this he goes to stop the penguin but
Ronson to Wonder Woman who's angry he
didn't call her you were gonna stick by
me no matter what and then a little bat
condom break do you know what it's like
going to Planned Parenthood by yourself
I haven't a clue like gal gadot said no
to this but the penguin straps a bomb to
Supergirl is it even worth bringing up
why that doesn't make sense
Oscar it just frees free man and Robin
tries to save her ah yeah that's funny
damn it somebody won't get off of one
hand how many laughs I actually had but
Batman reveals it's actually the Riddler
because yeah why not you knew that she
was a dude all time Wow why'd you make
me kiss her I guess I woke up this
morning with a little case of the fuck
around oh thank God you made it unfunny
again thanks for feeling someone
balanced so I guess the dark web videos
the boys are searching through have
commercials and PSAs as this one warns
you to be kinder to the little children
who are secretly inside convenience
machines physical verbal emotional abuse
can't you see they're doing their best
remember machines they're full of kids
okay so this film's not very funny but
I'd say about three percent of it is
getting legit laughs out of me and I see
movies that couldn't even muster a
percent like if asked to see some of
these that short YouTube videos I
probably wouldn't be that insulted
either just forget about it or maybe
produce it's like giggle if it actually
was funny it's ironic the producer said
he wanted this to be like Funny or Die
because a lot of these probably would
have been better if the Funny or Die
people actually handle them but no we
need the gripping computer segways that
tie all of this together because it's a
movie right
totally we're showing on the
scream you know we can find movie 43
movie 43 are you prepared to have a
starving rat living out your eyeballs
and say this films honest to a fault but
it's more honest to a thankfully
considerate
we got a click this button do not take d
button
oh no you started it from the beginning
I really wouldn't rather have rat see
out of my eyeballs
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here letting you know
some of the conventions we have coming
up from June 7th to 9th is indy popcon
in indianapolis and you can get a
discount on tickets if you just use the
promo code awesome when purchasing them
from June 21st to the 23rd we have
planted bunk in Iowa this is our first
time at this one ensured to be a lot of
fun
and from July 6 to 7th its Salt City
Comic Con at the New York State
Fairgrounds in Syracuse New York we have
even more conventions this year but
these are the ones coming up so go to
the sites get the tickets drop on by and
say hi would love to see you
[Applause]
now that sketch opens with that I babe
device that was shown earlier ah
so that was a sneak peek of what was to
come
I'm sure went over as well as this sneak
peek went over so the eye babe has a fan
in her couch and the kids are putting
all sorts of body parts inside her
getting them chopped off at last quality
has returned to this movie I babe is a
music player it also looks and feels
exactly like a naked woman teenage boys
are physically attracted to naked women
our research doesn't support that sorry
commentary did you anticipate anybody
breaching the cooling system Dave that
was like a joke waking up looking as a
warm clock and going yeah I don't want
to be funny today and going back to
sleep they bring in the new eye babe
with a choice of color get it because
black people and Richard Gere fiddles
her gears oh for Christ's sake no we
understand why do you try everything to
get out of this again just when you're
wondering where is this all going by yep
that's it we needed a preview of this
early on in the film
that's like saying early on in the movie
monster get ready for Charlize Theron's
thirty-ninth blank welcome the gangster
on the computer is hijacked by other
gangsters looking for movie 43 man so
you know where movie 43 no the movie
that allows you to see into the future
okay it's not that funny yet but it does
keep my interest I do kind of want to
know where it's going actually doing
some research I just found out this link
wasn't shown in America it was an
alternative version shown in different
parts of the world really movie 43 you
need to be altered so it be more
accepted in other countries okay there's
one alteration that can be made that
everybody could agree on
the burg I leave happy I'd leave happy
the next sketch shows two kids on their
phones who start making out yeah
Nathan on a date for once I'm almost set
for life from super bad and How to Train
Your Dragon
I'm just working off a ticket I got for
littering the girl gets her period but
the boy confuses her blood for fruit
punch holy shit you're covered in blood
oh my god oh my god oh my god why do I
feel like my judging up this movie's
gonna be based before and after viewing
this sketch all right Patrick Warburton
you're like the bacon of comedy put you
in something it's instantly better
please save us the lining of Amanda's
internal organs just going out of it I
got frozen peas in a sponge Wow
it's like the sketch was digging its own
grave and rather than Warburton come in
to revive it he's like let me get you a
bigger shovel what the hell kind of sick
family squashes a large tomato and my
daughter's pants what did he you
directed this I'm selling shit to their
house Elizabeth Banks I made a vow never
to shit mail anyone from wet hot
American summer you got lucky
the girl in mid she's getting a period
and her father takes her home you don't
have a camping tarp I can borrow do you
I should be more surprised if something
like that wasn't said the Sun pulls
Warburton's finger he farts and they
watch the game right after a Tampax
commercial where a woman gets eaten by a
shark in a strange way that should be
funny but movie 43 is kind of like
antimatter it shouldn't exist but
somehow it does the next sketch has
johnny Knoxville and Sean William Scott
as roommates who are moving out because
one slept with the others girlfriend but
who cares cuz he captured a leprechaun
for his birthday
played by Gerard Butler because of
course the last thing you'll ever see is
my cock don't look at him he was the
fucking dough tonight saunter off when I
fuck you with a pair of rusty scissors
okay even as a leprechaun with a
high-pitched voice drop Butler Estill
County badass just came away from a
phantom mask and we're good if
Cristi Irish take fish by the way brett
ratner directed this one I have no
reason to mention that I just want you
to hate it as much as possible the phone
rings and it's another leprechaun saying
he'll bring them the gold it appears to
them at the front door and he drags it
down to the basement the sketch might
redeem itself if there's a Warwick Davis
cameo coming up you get all these
assholes in know Warwick Davis
he said yes to five leprechaun sequels
do you really think he'd say no to movie
we'll get him anyway the other
leprechaun also played by Butler attacks
them but get shot by Knoxville they
throw them out with the trash which I'll
admit is a little funny and Knoxville
reveals the final part of his gift a
faerie upstairs what the hell am I
supposed to do with a fairy I suck cock
for gold coins this was a Radner film
alright the next sketch has Hailey's
Barry fulfilling a bet she made when she
was drunk that she couldn't do something
worse than Catwoman I've been on so many
blind dates in the past year and they
all are the same okay where are you from
where's your sister do why does my
outfit look like Miss Piggy melted onto
it let's play a game okay have you
played truth or dare they start playing
truth or dare and honestly it almost
sounds like a normal conversation yeah
for this movie I dare you to go and
pinch his ass to her credit she's dared
much weirder things like she once dared
a guy to put her in a John wick movie
and nobody knows why she was there don't
have to be here I can go home and watch
Family Guy right now if you don't want
to play Sundays on Fox check your local
listings he goes to grab the guy's ass
and he punches him so he dares her to
blow out a blind kids birthday candles
at least it's creatively mean-spirited
you can guess where it goes from here
they keep making more and more crazy
dares including getting a dick tattooed
on his face and her making guacamole
with her breasts
Jesus this movie's gonna be one big
censor bar by the time it's done
and the sad thing is most people would
prefer that that there's finally end
with them getting plastic surgery so she
looks like Howard the Duck and he looks
like Austin Michael Jackson Powers just
not
attracted to Asian men it's like if all
the latex from the money Python movies
bunked all the latex from the Eddie
Murphy movies the boys finally find
movie 43 and like I said before I
definitely couldn't predict this 43 we
triggered the top-secret Cold War
initiative to control the mind of every
American citizen
let's girl it on me a bit I need to be a
lottery nope all right it's settled
the whole film should have been this the
pointless Segway with no celebrities
that are usually an afterthought in
anthology movies is honestly the
funniest and most creative part of a
flank if they simply stuck with this it
could have been a terminator meets Hot
Tub Time Machine I'm kind of pissed we
didn't get an entire movie around this
the world starts to explode and the
little brother is the only one who can
stop it with his computer but you
guessed it the computer has viruses so
the earth gets news leaving the kids to
survive in the apocalypse years later
one of them finds the laptop asking if
he wants to turn back the world to the
way it was the boy says yes and the
computer reports that it's impossible
and he should just instead watch a movie
those also under taining wait no that
you Guinea Jackson coach T Ellison hi oh
so the next sketch is about the first
black basketball team going against an
all-white basketball team with Terrence
Howard as the coach let me guess the one
joke is you're black they're white and
this isn't hockey
you're black white this game guys who is
that funny way did I skip to the ending
there was really nothing else after that
but wait there's 17 minutes left what
was even the final joke the whites get
one point and they win racism ha that's
really the last joke of the movie but
hold on there can't be 17
of credits that makes no sense even if
it has bloopers or deleted scenes that's
still 17 minutes
in fact wait where's the James Goodwin
oh they're showing it now in the credits
kay this is bezel bezel is about a guy
who owns a cartoon cat that looks like
Ren & Stimpy is being choked by Homer
Simpson's ass I just don't think he
likes me very much
oh come on he loves you really fear not
I'll get revenge by directing my own
shitty sketch diesel makes threats to
banks his character and starts jerking
off to pictures of his master this is
definitely old school Twitter James Gunn
directing this he pisses on her because
peepee and she threatens to leave the
guy unless he puts her first he does
exactly that but bezel gets his revenge
by running over her and shooting her she
survives there fine and beats him at a
kid's birthday party resulting in the
kid stabbing her to death with cake
forks give it a point for random
originality but are we finally done
you sure okay well if you can't even do
your closing credits that smoothly
that's kind of the sign you're watching
a shitty movie movie 43 is stupid
unfocused lazily grotesque and most of
the time not funny which easily makes it
one of the worst movies ever made or
just stupid
unfocused lazily grotesque in most of
the time of money I'll be honest I've
seen comedies far worse than this I at
least chuckled a couple times and even
found the computer segues pretty clever
and how they built on top of every joke
so why is it called as Richard Roeper
put it the Citizen Kane of awful well I
think a lot of that has to do with how
many big stars are in it how incredibly
wasted they are and that they're United
not in a smart comedy but in a desperate
shock value comedy that's a felon cast
with a bunch of nobodies people would
probably forget it even existed but it
wasn't it had a lot of big names who I
guess we're just looking for vindication
that no matter how bad a film they would
make later is at least it wasn't movie
43 it's pretty lame and most of the time
it doesn't work but is it the worst
comedy ever made I don't think so I just
think it's a bad movie but don't get me
wrong bad is still bad enough not gonna
stash your credit Guy remember it so you
don't have to I'll see you in church
hey Doug Walker here and this week's
charity shout out is definitely a unique
one it's called the innocence project
the innocence project founded in 1992 at
the Cardozo School of Law exonerates the
wrongly convicted who DNA testing and
reforms the criminal justice system to
prevent future injustice their mission
is to set free the staggering number of
innocent people who remain incarcerated
and to bring reform to the system
responsible for their unjust
imprisonment to date 365 people in the
United States have been exonerated by
DNA testing including 20 who were
serving time on death row it's crazy to
think these people serve time for doing
no wrong
but because of good organizations like
these they no longer have to they look
to exonerate the innocent improve
legislation reform the laws that allow
wrongful conviction to happen and
support those who are looking to improve
their lives and start over
click on the link and make sure that
innocent people are still treated justly
in the justice system
you
[Music]